is about Word of Mouth here's how I used
to get tons of reviews five stars when I
opened every new facility is that I
would just say hey I will give you all
these t-shirts that I would wear every
day because they'd be like I want one of
those I'd be like there's only one way
you can get them which is you leave me a
review on Yelp and Google and make a
post on Facebook you can copy and paste
the same review I don't care just
screenshot up send them to me and I'll
send you a t-shirt overnight I would get
a hundred and something reviews of fall
three and the Facebook post anybody who
commented or liked it I'd be like yo but
that's like when I see local business I
have like 13 five stars like dude one
email you can get 150 and get so many
more people who are searching and get
all the referrals to all the people who
post